Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. There was a majestic, rapturous, and even seductive something in this first outbreak of the people from which one could escape only with difficulty. And in spite of all my hatred and aversion for war, I should not like to have missed the memory of those first days. As never before, thousands and hundreds of thousands felt what they should have felt in peacetime,
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周的加更剧集、无广告收听体验、抢先收听系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。在这次民众的首次爆发中，有一种宏伟、狂喜甚至诱人的东西，让人难以逃脱。尽管我憎恨并厌恶战争，但我并不希望错过对那最初几天的记忆。成千上万的人，前所未有地感受到了他们在和平时期本应感受到的东西，
that they belonged together. A city of two million, a country of nearly fifty million, in that hour felt that they were participating in world history, in a moment which would never recur, and that each one was called upon to cast his infinitesimal self into the glowing mass, there to be purified of all selfishness. All differences of class, rank and language were flooded over at that moment by the rushing feeling of fraternity. Strangers spoke to one another in the streets. People who had avoided each other for years shook hands. Everywhere, one saw excited faces. So that was Stefan Zweig, the great Austrian writer in The World of Yesterday, which he wrote in 1942 in the midst of a second terrible world war about the outbreak of the First World War. And Dominic, we quoted him at the beginning of our last episode, which was the final episode about the murder in Sarajevo of Archduke Franz
那就是他们属于彼此。一个两百万人口的城市，一个近五千万人口的国家，在那一刻感到他们正在参与世界历史，参与一个永不再现的时刻，每个人都被召唤着将自己微不足道的个体投入到那炽热的洪流中，在那里洗净所有的自私。阶级、等级和语言的所有差异，在那一刻都被那奔涌而来的兄弟情谊所淹没。陌生人在街上交谈。多年来一直回避对方的人握手言和。到处都能看到兴奋的面孔。以上就是奥地利伟大作家斯蒂芬·茨威格在《昨日的世界》中所写的内容，他在1942年第二次可怕的世界大战期间，回顾了第一次世界大战的爆发。多米尼克，我们在上一集的开头引用过他，那一集是关于萨拉热窝刺杀弗朗茨大公的最后一集。
Ferdinand. And we're now beginning a kind of sister series to that, where we look at how that murder, that assassination, led Europe to the outbreak of war. And I guess the thing that lots of people think they know is that the war was greeted with great enthusiasm and that it was kind of driven by emotions and feelings of jingoism and that this is an explanation for what happened. But the truth is much more complex, isn't it? It is more complicated. And of course, that reading could hardly be more darkly ironic, because as we said at the end of our Sarajevo series, Stefan Zweig is one of those people.
费迪南德。我们现在开始一个类似姊妹篇的系列，探讨那场谋杀、那次刺杀是如何将欧洲引向战争爆发的。我想很多人自以为知道的是，战争受到了极大的欢迎，它是被情绪和沙文主义情感所驱动的，这就是对所发生之事的解释。但事实要复杂得多，不是吗？确实更复杂。当然，这种解读几乎不可能更具讽刺意味了，因为正如我们在萨拉热窝系列结尾所说，斯蒂芬·茨威格就是其中之一。
His writings have come to embody the lost world of the Habsburg Empire, of kind of Europe before the fall, I suppose. That moment that he's talking about is arguably the greatest calamity in human history because it is from that moment, the outbreak of the First World War, that all the horrors of the 20th century were to flow. So obviously the First World War itself, the rise of Nazism, the rise of Bolshevism, the Second World War, the Holocaust, communism, the Cold War, all of these things.
他的作品已经成为哈布斯堡帝国失落世界的化身，我想，那是某种陷落前的欧洲。他所谈论的那个时刻，可以说是人类历史上最大的灾难，因为正是从那一刻起，即第一次世界大战的爆发，200世纪所有的恐怖都将随之而来。所以很明显，第一次世界大战本身、纳粹主义的兴起、布尔什维克主义的兴起、第二次世界大战、大屠杀、共产主义、冷战，所有这些事情。
The division of Europe. The division of Europe, exactly. And actually the division of Europe, which obviously cuts right through the world that he's talking about, that Habsburg empire. Yeah. The Austro-Hungarian empire gets divided on either side of the Iron Curtain. The world that belonged together.
欧洲的分裂。正是欧洲的分裂。实际上，欧洲的分裂显然直接切断了他所谈论的那个世界，即哈布斯堡帝国。是的。奥匈帝国被铁幕一分为二。那个曾经属于彼此的世界。
Yeah. You know, that's all going to be sundered forever. Well, not forever, but for generations. And so I suppose the moment that war breaks out, people are asking why, aren't they? In your notes here, you quote Rebecca West in The Black Lamb and Grey Falcon, and she's at the town hall in Sarajevo. She writes, leaning from the balcony, I said, I shall never be able to understand how it happened. It is not that there are too few facts available, but that there are too many. And that is the challenge really, isn't it? Because,
是的。你知道，这一切都将永远被撕裂。好吧，不是永远，但至少几代人是这样。所以我想，战争爆发的那一刻，人们都在问为什么，不是吗？在你的笔记里，你引用了丽贝卡·韦斯特在《黑羊与灰鹰》中的话，当时她在萨拉热窝的市政厅。她写道，从阳台上探出身子，我说，我永远无法理解这是怎么发生的。并不是因为可用的事实太少，而是因为太多了。这确实是挑战，不是吗？因为，
you know, we did an episode on the cause of the First World War. Is it militarism? Is it nationalism? Is it the Kaiser wearing the wrong deck shoes at cows? I mean, all of these have obviously been advanced as theories. Right. One of them only by you, but let's continue. No, I think distinguished historians have made that proposition. But one way that's become very popular with historians recently, Christopher Clarke and sleepwalkers and various other scholars, is to say, well, actually, you know, let's park the idea that there are broad abstract nouns hovering around.
你知道，我们做过一期关于第一次世界大战起因的节目。是军国主义吗？是民族主义吗？是德皇在考斯穿错了甲板鞋吗？我的意思是，所有这些显然都被作为理论提出来过。没错。其中一个只有你提过，但我们继续吧。不，我认为杰出的历史学家们已经提出了这个命题。但最近在历史学家中变得非常流行的一种方式，比如克里斯托弗·克拉克和《梦游者》以及其他各种学者，他们会说，好吧，实际上，让我们先搁置那些悬而未决的宽泛抽象名词的想法。
Let's remind ourselves that actually it's about individuals in contingent circumstances. And this is obviously a kind of pre-internet age. So these are people who are operating far more in the dark than perhaps, I mean, obviously we know they didn't have the internet, but I think we are now so accustomed to an absolute blizzard of facts and news and the idea that people in different capitals can communicate with each other that perhaps we forget that back in 1914, the power players in the various countries, the various great powers and the second division powers were kind of operating a bit in the dark.
让我们提醒自己，实际上这关乎特定环境下的个人。这显然是一个前互联网时代。所以这些人是在黑暗中摸索，比我们现在——我的意思是，显然我们知道他们没有互联网，但我认为我们现在已经习惯了事实和新闻的狂轰滥炸，习惯了不同首都之间可以互相交流的想法，以至于我们可能忘记了在1914年，各国、各列强和二流强国的权力玩家们是在某种程度上摸黑行事。
A little bit. Yeah, I think that's absolutely right, Tom. They're depending so much on telegrams, so they're not ringing each other. That's not possible. They're sending telegrams to their ambassadors who then have to go and call a meeting with somebody else. So it's all kind of Chinese whispers to some extent. I think you're absolutely right.
有一点。是的，我认为这绝对正确，汤姆。他们太依赖电报了，所以他们不能互相打电话。那是不可能的。他们给大使发报，大使再去和别人约见。所以在某种程度上，这都是传声筒游戏。我认为你绝对正确。
That emphasis on individuals is really important. There's a brilliant book actually called July Crisis by a guy called Thomas Otte. So for people who've read Christopher Clarke's The Sleepwalkers, if you found it a little bit light and frivolous, Thomas Otte's is the book for you. So he says at the beginning of that book, the decision to mobilize millions of men to send them to do and die in the battlefield were not made by anonymous factors. They were made by real people. And he says, you know, this is what we should look at. Count Berchtold, Theobald von Bettmann-Holweg, President Poincaré in France, Asquith and Gray in Britain, and so on and so forth. These people, you know,
对个人的强调非常重要。实际上有一本很棒的书叫《七月危机》，作者叫托马斯·奥特。所以对于读过克里斯托弗·克拉克的《梦游者》的人来说，如果你觉得那本书有点轻浮，托马斯·奥特的书就是为你准备的。所以他在书的开头说，动员数百万人送他们去战场作战并牺牲的决定，并不是由匿名因素做出的。它们是由真实的人做出的。他说，你知道，这才是我们应该关注的。贝希托尔德伯爵、特奥巴尔德·冯·贝特曼-霍尔维格、法国总统普恩加莱、英国的阿斯奎斯和格雷，等等。这些人，你知道，
they have the power of life and death over millions and they make the decisions the crucial decisions and the thing is they have always or almost always been completely caricatured in the popular imagination yeah you could argue these are some of the most caricatured people in all history because the classic thing that everybody says about them is that they are nationalistic reactionary warmongering old men who sent young men to die. And that is, I mean, that's something that's very current still today, isn't it? That kind of view of them. Yeah. I literally Googled old men, first world war. And the first thing that came up was a column in the Guardian by George Monbiot. And he ended his column about the first
他们掌握着数百万人的生杀大权，他们做出了决定，关键的决定，问题是，他们在大众想象中一直或几乎一直被完全漫画化了。是的，你可以说这是历史上被漫画化最严重的一群人，因为每个人对他们的经典评价是，他们是民族主义、反动、好战的老人，把年轻人送去送死。这在今天依然非常流行，不是吗？那种对他们的看法。是的。我真的在谷歌上搜了“老人，第一次世界大战”。出来的第一条就是《卫报》上乔治·蒙比奥的一篇专栏。他在关于第一次世界大战的专栏结尾说，
world war by saying the old men of Europe decided that they would rather kill their children than change their policies. And I think that's just wrong. It's just not right. Yeah, sure. But you can see why people think that, because that is a story that is being told within a year of the outbreak of war. So there's Kipling's terrible lines that presumably are haunted by the fact that his son John dies in the Battle of Luz a year after the outbreak of war.
欧洲的老人们决定，他们宁愿杀死自己的孩子，也不愿改变他们的政策。我认为这完全错了。这根本不对。是的，当然。但你可以理解为什么人们会这么想，因为这是一个在战争爆发一年内就被讲述的故事。所以有吉卜林那可怕的诗句，大概是因为他在战争爆发一年后，他的儿子约翰在卢斯战役中阵亡而深受困扰。
If any question why we died, i.e. the young of Europe, tell them, because our fathers lied. And then there's the terrible poem that Wilfred Owen writes, who dies right at the end of the war. And he has the myth of Abraham about to sacrifice his son Isaac. And then the angel appears and says, don't sacrifice him. And in Owen's version, Abraham is offered a ram and told to sacrifice it. But the old man would not so, but slew his son and half the seed of Europe one by one. And then Benjamin Britten wrote Requiem for War about that. So it is part of the culture that derives from the experience of the war itself, isn't it? And it has a power, inherent kind of mythic power.
如果有人问我们为何而死，即欧洲的年轻人，告诉他们，因为我们的父亲撒了谎。还有威尔弗雷德·欧文写的可怕的诗，他在战争快结束时阵亡。他有亚伯拉罕准备牺牲儿子以撒的神话。然后天使出现说，不要牺牲他。在欧文的版本中，亚伯拉罕得到了一只公羊，被告知去牺牲它。但老人不肯，却一个接一个地杀死了他的儿子和欧洲一半的种子。然后本杰明·布里顿为此写了《战争安魂曲》。所以这是源于战争本身经历的文化的一部分，不是吗？它有一种力量，一种内在的神话力量。
You know, Owen's use of the Bible there. I mean, it's really resonant. The idea of doomed youth, you know, the anthem for doomed youth. Yeah. Doomed youth and the people who have doomed the youngsters are their elders. Yeah, it's got an enormous power, but it's not right. These aren't actually very old men. So most of the people who make the big decisions are actually in the prime of their lives. They're not reactionary. Many of them are actually political moderates or in Britain, they're liberals. Well, in Germany as well, right?
你知道，欧文在那里对圣经的使用。我的意思是，它真的很有共鸣。注定年轻人的想法，你知道，为注定年轻人而作的赞歌。是的，注定年轻人，而那些注定年轻人命运的人是他们的长辈。是的，它有巨大的力量，但它是不对的。这些人实际上并不是非常老的人。所以大多数做出重大决定的人实际上正处于他们生命的黄金时期。他们不是反动派。他们中的许多人实际上是政治温和派，或者在英国，他们是自由派。好吧，在德国也是，对吧？
Because the social democrats in Germany had just won about a third of the vote, I think, in an election. Yeah, and they agreed to go along with the war. Sometimes sort of left-wing historians would say they were fueled by a terrible fear of revolution. But actually, when you get down into the weeds, as it were, of the crucial decisions, the idea of revolution, being frightened of socialism and stuff, that doesn't feature at all. Are they nationalists? It's always said these are wars driven by nationalism. But actually, a lot of the people we'll talk about in this series are not nationalists. They are internationalists. They are cosmopolitan people. We will see how everybody has the wrong surname because, you know, the Austrian guy has a
因为德国的社会民主党在选举中刚刚赢得了大约三分之一的选票，我想。是的，他们同意支持战争。有时左翼历史学家会说他们是被对革命的恐惧所驱使。但实际上，当你深入到关键决策的细节中时，对革命的想法、对社会主义的恐惧之类的东西，根本就没有出现过。他们是民族主义者吗？人们总是说这些战争是由民族主义驱动的。但实际上，我们将在这个系列中谈论的许多人并不是民族主义者。他们是国际主义者。他们是世界主义者。我们将看到每个人都有错误的姓氏，因为，你知道，那个奥地利人有一个
Russian sounding surname. The Russian ambassador sounds German because these are, as it were, often citizens of the world, very fluent in other languages, friends in other countries, all of that kind of thing. Well, the Kaiser and the Tsar communicate in English. Yeah. And of course, you know, all the various emperors and kings are all descended from Queen Victoria. So it's literally a family affair. Yeah.
听起来像俄语的姓氏。俄国大使听起来像德国人，因为这些人，正如人们所说，往往是世界公民，精通其他语言，在其他国家有朋友，诸如此类。好吧，德皇和沙皇用英语交流。是的。当然，你知道，所有不同的皇帝和国王都是维多利亚女王的后裔。所以这真的是一场家庭事务。是的。
When the Russian foreign minister and the German ambassador are talking to each other, they will often talk in French. And the other thing is when these people are having these crucial conversations, as we will see in this series, at the end of the July crisis, so let's say the month or so after the assassination of Franz Ferdinand Sofie, at the end of that period, many of the people we will be talking about have nervous breakdowns, or they literally start crying in front of each other because they are so ravaged by anxiety and agony and guilt and regret about what has happened. These are not warmongers, I wouldn't say, by any stretch of
当俄国外交部长和德国大使交谈时，他们通常会用法语。另一件事是，当这些人进行这些关键对话时，正如我们在这个系列中将看到的，在七月危机结束时，也就是弗朗茨·费迪南德和索菲遇刺后的一个月左右，在那个时期结束时，我们谈论的许多人都有精神崩溃，或者他们在彼此面前真的开始哭泣，因为他们被焦虑、痛苦、内疚和对所发生之事的遗憾所折磨。我绝不会说他们是好战分子，
the imagination. In which case, it only makes the mystery all the greater, isn't it? How these people ended up leading their countries into a war that nobody wanted. Well, some people did want the war. I think we should say that right away. Wars don't happen by accident. Somebody has to will it. Somebody has to make those crucial decisions. One of the points I'd make right at the beginning is we only really do this with the First World War. Up to this point, if you talked about the Crimean War,
无论如何。在这种情况下，这只会让谜团变得更大，不是吗？这些人是如何最终领导他们的国家走向一场没人想要的战争的。好吧，有些人确实想要战争。我想我们应该马上说出来。战争不会偶然发生。有人必须意愿它。有人必须做出那些关键的决定。我一开始要提出的观点之一是，我们只在第一次世界大战中才真正这样做。到目前为止，如果你谈论克里米亚战争、
the Napoleonic Wars, the Franco-Prussian War, the Seven Years' War, whatever, we wouldn't find it inexplicable that these wars happened. I mean, people at the time thought it was perfectly reasonable that wars happened. They might say it's sad that people die, but they knew that war was a completely rational, they regarded it as an explicable tool of foreign policy. They did. But I mean, correct me if I'm wrong here, but they thought that local wars were an acceptable tool of policy.
拿破仑战争、普法战争、七年战争，无论什么，我们都不会觉得这些战争的发生是不可解释的。我的意思是，当时的人们认为战争的发生是完全合理的。他们可能会说人们死去很悲伤，但他们知道战争是一种完全理性的、他们将其视为一种可解释的外交政策工具。他们确实是这样。但我的意思是，如果我错了请纠正我，但他们认为局部战争是一种可接受的政策工具。
Yeah. What everyone was terrified of was a general European war. I mean, maybe there aren't. I accept your point that there are certain actors in this who actually are quite keen on a general European conflagration. But most people, I get the impression, have a sense that this will be something terrible. They don't think it's going to be over by Christmas. They know that they are on the edge of a precipice. Well, I think it's fair to say, Tom, nobody gets the war they want.
是的。每个人都感到恐惧的是一场全面的欧洲战争。我的意思是，也许没有。我接受你的观点，即其中有一些参与者确实非常渴望一场全面的欧洲大火。但大多数人，我得到的印象是，他们有一种感觉，这将是一件可怕的事情。他们不认为战争会在圣诞节前结束。他们知道他们正处于悬崖边缘。好吧，我认为公平地说，汤姆，没有人能得到他们想要的战争。
There are people in the story who want a war. I express myself badly. Nobody wants the war they get. And how they do get it, That is the mystery, isn't it? I will say one other thing, actually. I think it really matters that the trigger is as it is. When we said we were doing a Sarajevo series and we put up pictures when we went to Sarajevo on social media and we said, you know, a fateful place changed the course of world history. Some of the replies people said, not faithful at all. The war was inevitable. You know, it was always coming. I think that's wrong. I think the fact that the victim was who he was, actually two victims. We always forget one of the victims, Franz Ferdinand and his wife, Sophie, that the killer was Gavrilo Princip and that it happened in Sarajevo.
故事里确实有人想要战争。我表达得不好。没有人能得到他们所得到的战争。他们是如何得到的，这才是谜，不是吗？我还要说一件事，实际上。我认为触发因素是什么真的很重要。当我们说我们要做一个萨拉热窝系列，我们在社交媒体上发布了我们去萨拉热窝的照片，我们说，你知道，一个改变世界历史进程的宿命之地。一些回复说，根本不是宿命。战争是不可避免的。你知道，它总是会来的。我认为那是错的。我认为受害者是谁，实际上是两个受害者。我们总是忘记其中一个受害者，弗朗茨·费迪南德和他的妻子索菲，凶手是加夫里洛·普林西普，而且它发生在萨拉热窝，这一事实，
I think they are massively important in explaining why things happen as they do. Right. So people who want to hear more about the murder, we've just done a four part series. So let's assume that they are dead. Yeah, well, they are. And the reverberations are spreading out from Sarajevo towards Austria and across Europe. So how do we go from an assassination happening? And it's a terrible thing, but assassinations, as we said in the previous series, lots of people are getting killed yeah we listed all the kind of various members of royalty and the presidents and so on who were assassinated in the 20th century so what is it about this assassination that is different right well let's start from the very beginning so the news reaches
我认为它们在解释为什么事情会这样发生方面非常重要。好的。所以想听更多关于谋杀案的人，我们刚刚做了一个四部分的系列。所以让我们假设他们已经死了。是的，好吧，他们确实死了。余波正从萨拉热窝向奥地利和整个欧洲蔓延。那么我们是如何从一场刺杀发生的？这是一件可怕的事情，但刺杀，正如我们在上一系列中所说的，很多人都在被杀，是的，我们列出了20世纪被刺杀的各种皇室成员和总统等等，那么这次刺杀有什么不同呢？好的，让我们从头开始。所以消息传到
vienna as we described at the end of the last series news reaches vienna within hours so we talked about stefan zweig in our sarajevo series We had a scene there of him being in a park and the band stopping playing. That is literally what happens. And it is a bit of a myth that the Austrians didn't care. It's often said, oh, Franz Ferdinand wasn't very popular. Who cared? That's not right. When you look at the press coverage, the newspapers, editorials talk about the monstrous of it all, our heir to the throne, the person on whom we'd placed all our hopes. Some newspapers in the Habsburg monarchy have big pictures of the orphaned children, and they will play a part in the popular sort of discourse in Austria-Hungary in the next few days. So it is a shocking event in and of itself. It is not nothing. I think it's sometimes dismissed, the assassination.
维也纳，正如我们在上一系列结尾所描述的那样，消息在几小时内传到了维也纳。所以我们在萨拉热窝系列中谈到了斯蒂芬·茨威格。我们在那里有一个场景，他在公园里，乐队停止了演奏。这确实就是发生的事情。奥地利人不在乎是一个神话。人们常说，哦，弗朗茨·费迪南德不是很受欢迎。谁在乎呢？那是不对的。当你查看媒体报道时，报纸、社论都在谈论这一切的怪异，我们的王位继承人，我们寄予厚望的人。哈布斯堡王朝的一些报纸有孤儿的大照片，它们将在接下来的几天里在奥匈帝国的流行话语中发挥作用。所以这本身就是一个令人震惊的事件。它不是什么都没有。我认为它有时被忽视了，这次刺杀。
Oh, there are loads of assassinations. And of course there are. But even in that context, it's still a shocking thing. And right away, the Viennese papers say, well, this isn't actually like an anarchist assassination. This is the fault of another country and of Serbia. They point the finger at Serbia. And of course, Tom, as we described last time, they're not wrong. The killers almost certainly were groomed by terrorist groups that were embedded in Serbian politics and the Serbian army.
哦，有很多刺杀。当然有。但即使在那种背景下，它仍然是一件令人震惊的事情。维也纳报纸立刻说，好吧，这实际上不像无政府主义者的刺杀。这是另一个国家和塞尔维亚的错。他们指责塞尔维亚。当然，汤姆，正如我们上次描述的那样，他们并没有错。凶手几乎可以肯定是受塞尔维亚政治和塞尔维亚军队中嵌入的恐怖组织培养的。
They were helped across the border by Serbian intelligence. And as we described in the last series, the Serbian prime minister almost certainly knew that something was up before the crime happened. What is worse, from the Austrian point of view, is that the people in Serbia are openly delighted by the killings. So they are really shocked by this, the Austrians. The ambassador and his consuls and whatnot, they write back to Vienna and they say people are celebrating, people are having toasts in the coffee houses, they're laughing and
他们在塞尔维亚情报部门的帮助下越过了边境。正如我们在上一系列中所描述的，塞尔维亚总理在犯罪发生前几乎肯定知道有什么事情要发生。更糟糕的是，从奥地利的观点来看，塞尔维亚的人们对杀戮公开感到高兴。所以奥地利人对此真的感到震惊。大使和他的领事们等等，他们写信回维也纳说人们在庆祝，人们在咖啡馆里敬酒，他们在大笑和
singing Serbian patriotic songs and whatnot. And the Serbian prime minister gives a really inflammatory speech the day after the assassinations where rather than sort of saying, oh gosh, what a terrible thing to have happened. We want to distance ourselves from this. The Serbian prime minister, Nikola Pasic, says, if the Austrians try to exploit this, we will defend ourselves and we will fulfill our duty to our country. And that obviously sends quite the wrong message as far as the Austrians are concerned. Right. And remember as well, the Austrians have already been extremely anxious about Serbia.
唱着塞尔维亚爱国歌曲等等。塞尔维亚总理在刺杀发生后的第二天发表了一场非常煽动性的演讲，他没有说，哦天哪，发生了多么可怕的事情。我们想与此保持距离。塞尔维亚总理尼古拉·帕希奇说，如果奥地利人试图利用这一点，我们将保卫自己，我们将履行对国家的职责。这显然在奥地利人看来传达了完全错误的信息。好的。还要记住，奥地利人已经对塞尔维亚感到非常焦虑。
So we talked in the previous series about Austria-Hungary. Austria-Hungary has been in decline all through the reign of its current emperor, the 84-year-old Franz Joseph. It is this very strange empire, dual monarchy, half of it Austria, half of it Hungary, both sides governing a load of Slavs, Romanians, Italians, and whatever, Ukrainians. It kind of works. You can live your whole life under that system and be very happy and say, this is a great system.
所以我们在上一系列中谈到了奥匈帝国。奥匈帝国在现任皇帝、84岁的弗朗茨·约瑟夫的统治下一直处于衰落之中。这是一个非常奇怪的帝国，二元君主制，一半是奥地利，一半是匈牙利，双方都统治着大量的斯拉夫人、罗马尼亚人、意大利人等等，乌克兰人。它运作得还行。你可以一生都生活在那个体系下，并且非常快乐，说，这是一个伟大的体系。
I love it. But people have a tremendous sense of anxiety about decline and about fragmentation. And they look across their border at Serbia, which has doubled in size in the last two years. And the Serbs make no secret of their antipathy to Austria-Hungary, their belief that South Slavs living in the empire's borders should actually be part of Serbia. And there have been people, as we talked about in the previous series, within Austria-Hungary, most famously the head of their general staff, their chief general, who is a guy called Franz Conrad von Hützendorf, who have been saying, let's have a crack at the Serbs.
我喜欢它。但人们对衰落和分裂有一种巨大的焦虑感。他们看着边境对面的塞尔维亚，它在过去两年里规模翻了一番。塞尔维亚人毫不掩饰他们对奥匈帝国的反感，他们认为生活在帝国边境内的南斯拉夫人实际上应该是塞尔维亚的一部分。正如我们在上一系列中谈到的，在奥匈帝国内部，最著名的是他们的总参谋长，他们的首席将军，一个叫弗朗茨·康拉德·冯·赫岑多夫的人，他一直说，让我们给塞尔维亚一点颜色看看。
Let's launch a preemptive strike. You know, we have to settle this because they will eat away at our empire. So he had, remember we said he'd pressed for war 25 times in the course of the previous 12 months. And the Archduke Franz Ferdinand had resisted, which is part of the irony because he then gets cast as a kind of bellicose warmonger, but the opposite was the case. He was very much the spokesman for the Peace Party. Yeah. So with Franz Ferdinand gone, the person who's going to be the key decision maker is actually an old childhood friend of his. Now, all the Austrian people in this story, Tom,
让我们发动先发制人的打击。你知道，我们必须解决这个问题，因为他们会蚕食我们的帝国。所以他，记住我们说过他在过去12个月里25次要求战争。而弗朗茨·费迪南德大公一直抵制，这正是讽刺的一部分，因为他后来被塑造成一个好战的战争贩子，但事实恰恰相反。他非常是和平党的发言人。是的。所以随着弗朗茨·费迪南德的离去，将成为关键决策者的人实际上是他童年的老朋友。现在，这个故事里的所有奥地利人，汤姆，
have absolutely splendid names. Would you like to have a go at the Austrian foreign minister's name or would you like me to do it? Shall I have a crack? Go for it. I'll give it a go. Leopold Anton Johann Sigismund Josef Kosinus Ferdinand Graf Berchtold von und zu Ungarschitz. Is that right? Ungarschitz. Ungarschitz.
都有非常华丽的名字。你想试着读一下奥地利外交部长的名字，还是让我来？我来试一下？去吧。我来试一下。利奥波德·安东·约翰·西吉斯蒙德·约瑟夫·科西努斯·费迪南德·格拉夫·贝希托尔德·冯·温德·祖·翁加尔希茨。对吗？翁加尔希茨。翁加尔希茨。
Freitling und Pöhlitz. Yeah. Count Berchtold for short. So Count Berchtold, he's actually in many ways a very attractive man. He's a Hungarian magnate, so he has loads of lands in Hungary. He loves literature. He loves art and horses. Doesn't everyone in Austria-Hungary?
弗莱特林·温德·波利茨。是的。简称贝希托尔德伯爵。所以贝希托尔德伯爵，他在许多方面实际上是一个非常有吸引力的人。他是一位匈牙利大亨，所以在匈牙利有很多土地。他热爱文学。他热爱艺术和马匹。奥匈帝国的人不都这样吗？
I mean, this is very much the impression I get. I think they do, by law. Some people probably are more into the strudels and stuff. I don't know. A charming cavalier, says Tomasotti. He was seen as a man of conciliation and moderation and he had grown up with franz versland berchtold's wife had been one of sophie's best friends ever since they were girls okay so it's personal for him so it's personal he hears the news and he's at his castle which is now in the czech republic basically bucklau and he rushes by train to vienna and he goes straight into a
我的意思是，这确实是我得到的印象。我想他们法律上就是这样。有些人可能更喜欢果馅卷之类的东西。我不知道。托马斯·奥特说，一位迷人的骑士。他被视为一个和解与温和的人，他和弗朗茨·费迪南德一起长大，贝希托尔德的妻子从她们还是女孩时起就是索菲最好的朋友之一。好的，所以对他来说这是个人的。所以这是个人的，他听到消息，他在他的城堡里，现在基本上在捷克共和国，布克劳，他乘火车赶往维也纳，直接进入一个
meeting with general conrad so again it's a bit like, for our American listeners, for example, it's like the atmosphere after 9-11. They're right in a crisis meeting, what are we going to do? And Conrad says, he's still kind of Dick Cheney figure, and he says, okay, I've been telling you for years, we have to do this. If you have a poisonous adder at your heel, you stamp on its head, you do not wait for the lethal bite. And Bertolt wrote in his diary, he said, Conrad, who's quite a gloomy figure because he's got this tangled love life,
与康拉德将军的会议，所以这又有点像，对我们的美国听众来说，例如，就像9-11之后的氛围。他们正处于危机会议中，我们要怎么办？康拉德说，他仍然是那种迪克·切尼式的人物，他说，好吧，我多年来一直告诉你，我们必须这样做。如果你的脚后跟有一条毒蛇，你就踩住它的头，你不会等它咬你一口。贝希托尔德在他的日记里写道，他说，康拉德，他是一个相当忧郁的人物，因为他有这种纠缠不清的爱情生活，
hasn't he, with Gina. Yes, he just writes love letters to her that he never sends. That he never sends. He's got a big scrapbook. So Conrad, with a faraway look of melancholy on his fine featured face, he concluded emphatically with three words,
不是吗，和吉娜。是的，他只是写情书给她，但他从不寄出。他从不寄出。他有一个大剪贴簿。所以康拉德，带着一种忧郁的远眺，在他那轮廓分明的脸上，他用三个词强调地总结道，
war, war, war. So there we have one kind of leadership group who clearly do want a war. They don't want a world war, but they want a war against Serbia for what they see as completely understandable and justifiable reasons. All across the Austrian diplomatic service, and especially in Belgrade, people are saying, come on now, enough. We can't just let ourselves be humiliated on the world stage at the assassination of our heir and his wife. You've got to punish that. And because issues of prestige, national prestige, will be a running theme throughout the story, won't it? And people are anxious that if that prestige is damaged, it will be bad for them.
战争，战争，战争。所以我们那里有一个领导小组，他们显然确实想要战争。他们不想要世界大战，但他们想要一场针对塞尔维亚的战争，因为他们认为这是完全可以理解和正当的理由。在整个奥地利外交部门，特别是在贝尔格莱德，人们都在说，来吧，够了。我们不能就这样让我们的继承人和他的妻子在世界舞台上被刺杀而蒙羞。你必须惩罚它。而且因为声望问题，国家声望，将成为整个故事的一个贯穿主题，不是吗？人们担心如果那种声望受损，对他们来说会很糟糕。
And so therefore, planning a war of aggression in a way is a defensive measure. Right. The Austrians see this as completely defensive. They say we have been provoked and provoked and provoked. And if we do not act now, when would we ever act? And do you know what, Tom? I don't think you have to be particularly Austrophile to see why that would seem illogical. I mean, put it this way. We did a podcast series
所以，以某种方式策划一场侵略战争是一种防御措施。好的。奥地利人认为这完全是防御性的。他们说我们被挑衅、挑衅、再挑衅。如果我们现在不采取行动，我们什么时候才会采取行动？你知道吗，汤姆，我不认为你必须特别亲奥地利才能看出为什么这看起来不合逻辑。我的意思是，这样说吧。我们做了一个播客系列
about JFK. Imagine the Cubans had assassinated JFK. It had been proved. Would Washington have just said, oh, well, we'll let it go. We'll file a complaint at the International Criminal Court. Of course they wouldn't. Well, I mean, it's so interesting, isn't it? Because Kennedy was obsessed by this. So Barbara Tuchman's book, The Guns of August, he was obsessed by it. And he felt that he was trying to learn the lessons for that during the Cuban Missile Crisis. And then I think LBJ, likewise, he was determined not to generate a kind of First World War scenario after Kennedy's death. So he was very anxious about that because he had the lesson in front of him. Well, they don't have that lesson, right? This has not happened before. They don't have that lesson. So they don't know what's going to happen.
关于肯尼迪。想象一下古巴人刺杀了肯尼迪。如果已经证明了。华盛顿会说，哦，好吧，我们算了吧。我们会在国际刑事法院提起诉讼。他们当然不会。我的意思是，这太有趣了，不是吗？因为肯尼迪对此很着迷。所以芭芭拉·塔奇曼的书《八月的炮火》，他对此很着迷。他觉得他在古巴导弹危机期间试图从中吸取教训。然后我想林登·约翰逊，同样地，他决心在肯尼迪去世后不制造那种第一次世界大战的场景。所以他对此非常焦虑，因为他面前有那个教训。好吧，他们没有那个教训，对吧？这以前没有发生过。他们没有那个教训。所以他们不知道会发生什么。
So we're talking about 28th, 29th of June. There's lots of talk in the Austrian foreign ministry and elsewhere, settle accounts, as they put it, with Serbia. But of course, what does that mean? Does it mean that you crush it or does it mean you annex it? What do you do? And also, what does it mean for the rest of Europe? In the world of alliances, what are the consequences?
所以我们谈论的是6月28日、29日。奥地利外交部和其他地方有很多谈话，正如他们所说，与塞尔维亚算账。但当然，那意味着什么？这意味着你粉碎它，还是意味着你吞并它？你做什么？而且，这对欧洲其他国家意味着什么？在联盟的世界里，后果是什么？
And right from the start, the amazing thing, the really extraordinary thing about the Austrian response is they don't really think about that second question at all. All the historians who've written about it talk about their tunnel vision. They are just thinking about Serbia and they think, well, the rest of the world can take care of itself. We're not going to worry about that now. And I think part of that is they clearly feel very embattled and encircled. And they just think we can only concentrate on one thing at a time. And we're just going to think
从一开始，令人惊奇的事情，关于奥地利反应的真正非凡的事情是，他们根本没有真正考虑第二个问题。所有写过它的历史学家都谈到了他们的隧道视野。他们只是在考虑塞尔维亚，他们认为，好吧，世界其他地方可以照顾自己。我们现在不担心那个。我认为部分原因是他们显然感到非常受困和被包围。他们只是认为我们一次只能专注于一件事。我们只是要考虑
about Serbia and the rest will take care of itself. And then the second thing, I think they have a tremendous sense of sort of a ticking clock. Time is running out. And if we don't act on this right now, we can't have those conversations. So we haven't got time. Right. Because the longer they leave it, the more the shock of the assassination will fade on the international stage. Yeah. And the less sympathy there will be for any armed measures.
塞尔维亚，其余的会照顾自己。然后第二件事，我认为他们有一种某种滴答作响的时钟的感觉。时间不多了。如果我们现在不对此采取行动，我们就不能进行那些对话。所以我们没有时间了。好的。因为他们拖得越久，刺杀带来的冲击在国际舞台上就会消退得越多。是的。对任何武装措施的同情就会越少。
Yes. I also think they don't really think about the possibility of a world war because they are convinced that the Serbs will back down. They had issued two ultimatums to Serbia before in very recent years, one in 1908 over the annexation of Bosnia, and one in 1913 over the Serbs after the Balkan Wars had occupied Albania, and the Austrians told them to get out. And both times the Serbians had backed down. And Count Burke told this very urbane cosmopolitan, not a warmonger at all, but he says to his colleagues, listen, these people are just like anarchic, horrible children. And if you're
是的。我也认为他们并没有真正考虑世界大战的可能性，因为他们确信塞尔维亚人会退缩。他们在最近几年里向塞尔维亚发出了两次最后通牒，一次是1908年关于吞并波斯尼亚，一次是1913年巴尔干战争后塞尔维亚占领阿尔巴尼亚，奥地利人告诉他们离开。两次塞尔维亚人都退缩了。贝希托尔德伯爵这位非常文雅的世界主义者，根本不是好战分子，但他对他的同事说，听着，这些人就像无政府主义的、可怕的孩子。如果你
firm with them, they will back down and go away. And that's what we have to do. Well, unless they can appeal to another parent figure, which presumably lurks to the east in the form of Russia. Exactly. So Serbia does have this patron, Russia, their close allies. However, again, the Austrian Foreign Service say Russia is not ready for war. They're in the middle of a big rearmament program. They won't want to go to war until they finish that. Plus, they've had standoffs with the Russians before. So people often say, why is it this crisis rather than previous crises that causes the First World War? Because the Russians, for example, had backed down in 1908 when Austria had annexed Bosnia-Herzegovina. Well, the thing is, the Austrians say the Russians backed down too. The Serbs backed down,
对他们坚定，他们就会退缩并离开。这就是我们必须做的。好吧，除非他们能向另一个家长形象求助，这大概潜伏在东方，以俄罗斯的形式。正是如此。所以塞尔维亚确实有这个赞助人，俄罗斯，他们的亲密盟友。然而，奥地利外交部再次表示，俄罗斯还没有准备好战争。他们正处于一个大型重整军备计划的中间。在完成之前，他们不会想去打仗。加上，他们以前和俄国人有过对峙。所以人们经常问，为什么是这次危机而不是之前的危机导致了第一次世界大战？因为俄国人，例如，在1908年奥地利吞并波斯尼亚-黑塞哥维那时退缩了。好吧，问题是，奥地利人说俄国人也退缩了。塞尔维亚人退缩了，
the Russians backed down when you are strong. And of course, they are drawing from this the wrong lesson. They're thinking that if you back down twice, you'll back down a third time. Of course, there's always the possibility that if you've already backed down twice, you will say to yourself, never again. Because then your prestige will be damaged and that might threaten your security and the dominoes fall. Exactly. So by two days after the assassination, the Austrians had pretty much made up their minds.
当你强大时，俄国人退缩了。当然，他们从中得出了错误的教训。他们认为如果你退缩两次，你就会第三次退缩。当然，总有一种可能性，如果你已经退缩了两次，你会对自己说，再也不要了。因为那样你的声望会受损，那可能会威胁到你的安全，多米诺骨牌就会倒下。正是如此。所以到刺杀发生两天后，奥地利人已经基本下定了决心。
Count Berchtold goes to see the 84-year-old monarch Franz Josef at the Schönbrunn Palace. And he says, come on, we've made up our minds. Let's do this. And the monarch says, sure. Okay. I agree with you. Unfortunately, we will need to get the prime minister of Hungary on board. We can't just go straight into this because of course the dual monarchy system. And the prime minister of Hungary is a guy called Istvan Tisza. He's another kind of count landowner. He's from the Magyar gentry. He's a very impressive man, Tom. He was educated at Heidelberg and he's got a PhD from Oxford. He's very rich. He's very ruthless. He's very clever. he's a fanatical defender of hungarian interests magyar interests he's devoted to the monarchy but he's always looking to get a better deal for the hungarians and the one thing that he doesn't want is more slavs in the empire because that will
贝希托尔德伯爵去见84岁的君主弗朗茨·约瑟夫，在美泉宫。他说，来吧，我们已经下定决心了。让我们这样做。君主说，当然。好的。我同意你。不幸的是，我们需要让匈牙利总理加入。我们不能就这样直接进入这个，因为当然是二元君主制体系。匈牙利总理是一个叫伊斯特万·蒂萨的人。他是另一种伯爵地主。他来自马扎尔贵族。他是一个非常令人印象深刻的人，汤姆。他在海德堡受过教育，在牛津大学有博士学位。他非常有钱。他非常无情。他非常聪明。他是匈牙利利益、马扎尔利益的狂热捍卫者。他忠于君主制，但他总是寻求为匈牙利人争取更好的交易。他唯一不想要的就是帝国里有更多的斯拉夫人，因为那会
dilute the hungarian presence you see so count tisa says i don't like the idea of attacking serbia i don't want a whole load of new Slavs in the empire. He actually says that very afternoon, so the afternoon that Berchtold has gone to see Franz Josef at Schönbrunn, they meet and Count Tisza says, it would be a fatal mistake to make the abominable deed of Sarajevo a pretext for settling scores with Serbia. So you might think that with that, the chances of war are gone. The Austrians have talked about it for two days and bang, you're not going to have it. But Berchtold and the other people think, no, we can persuade this Hungarian guy because we will invoke our great friend, our great ally, the richest and most powerful country in Europe,
稀释匈牙利人的存在，你明白吗？所以蒂萨伯爵说，我不喜欢攻击塞尔维亚的想法，我不想要帝国里有大量新的斯拉夫人。他实际上就在那天下午说了，也就是贝希托尔德去美泉宫见弗朗茨·约瑟夫的那个下午，他们见面了，蒂萨伯爵说，把萨拉热窝的可憎行为作为与塞尔维亚算账的借口将是一个致命的错误。所以你可能认为有了那个，战争的机会就没了。奥地利人谈论了两天，砰，你不会有它了。但贝希托尔德和其他人认为，不，我们可以说服这个匈牙利人，因为我们将援引我们伟大的朋友，我们伟大的盟友，欧洲最富有、最强大的国家，
and they will sway him and they will persuade him to join us. And that country, Tom, is of course, Germany. Germany at last. Okay. So I think we should take a break now. And when we come back, Dominic, let's look at how the Austrians approached Germany in the context of their plans for attacking Serbia. But before we do that, let's look at what the Austrians approached Germany in the context of their plans for attacking Serbia. But before we do that, let's look at what is it that makes Germany a great power? And are there possibly any entertaining figures at the head of the German Empire? Are there indeed? Any entertaining figures who might rank as friends of the show?
他们会动摇他，他们会说服他加入我们。那个国家，汤姆，当然是德国。终于到德国了。好的。所以我认为我们现在应该休息一下。当我们回来时，多米尼克，让我们看看奥地利人在他们攻击塞尔维亚的计划背景下是如何接触德国的。但在我们做那件事之前，让我们看看是什么让德国成为一个大国？在德意志帝国首脑处是否有任何有趣的数字？确实有吗？任何可能被列为节目朋友的有趣数字？
You know, spoiler, there are. So don't go away. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. So, don't go away. Add free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets. Head to therestesentertainment.com. That's therestesentertainment.com. Hello and welcome back to The Rest Is History. And Dominic, we are moving from Vienna to Berlin, to the heart of the German Empire. And I guess that for most people, the cause of the First World War, certainly if you're British, will be tied up with an image of Germany as a militarist land, a land of shaven-headed Junkers wearing helmets with terrifying spikes on, a general sense of militarism. But that would be unfair to Bill Helmine Germany, wouldn't it?
你知道，剧透一下，有。所以不要走开。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《娱乐的余味》。所以，不要走开。无广告收听，加更剧集和抢先购买现场票。前往 therestesentertainment.com。那是 therestesentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》。多米尼克，我们正从维也纳前往柏林，前往德意志帝国的中心。我想对于大多数人来说，第一次世界大战的起因，当然如果你是英国人，会与德国作为军国主义土地的形象联系在一起，一个戴着有可怕尖刺头盔的剃光头容克地主的土地，一种军国主义的普遍感觉。但这对比尔海姆德国来说是不公平的，不是吗？
I think it probably would be a bit unfair. First of all, there is some truth in it, but it would be a bit unfair. People who've been listening to the rest of his history for the last three decades will know that we once did an episode about Wilhelmine Germany with Katja Heuer, a great friend of the show, and she was painting a picture of it. And it's a really interesting and complicated place. So Germany has only existed since 1870. It was created in the Franco-Prussian War and created, of course, in France at the Hall of Mirrors in Versailles. If you ever look at the painting, Google it. An amazing scene. Very medieval. All the German princes are there, generals, Bismarck. Because it's echoing the First Reich,
我想这可能有点不公平。首先，其中有一些事实，但它会有点不公平。过去三十年来一直收听《历史的余味》的人会知道，我们曾经和节目的好朋友卡佳·霍伊尔做过一期关于比尔海姆德国的节目，她描绘了它的画面。这是一个非常有趣和复杂的地方。所以德国自1870年以来才存在。它是在普法战争中创建的，当然是在法国凡尔赛的镜厅创建的。如果你看过那幅画，谷歌一下。一个惊人的场景。非常中世纪。所有的德国王子都在那里，将军们，俾斯麦。因为它在呼应第一帝国，
which was the Empire of Charlemagne, and now you have the Second Reich. Yeah, exactly. And they have a lot to be proud of. So they are a very militaristic country. The army has lots of privileges. The army is embedded in the politics of that world. Because, Dominic, just to re-emphasize this, it is the army that has given Germany its rank as the most dominant military power, not just in Central Europe, but in Europe. Yes. Displacing the power that previously had held that status, which was France. Yes, exactly. And France had not only been kind of richly humiliated by that kind of ritual in Versailles,
也就是查理曼大帝的帝国，现在你有第二帝国。是的，正是如此。他们有很多值得骄傲的地方。所以他们是一个非常军国主义的国家。军队有很多特权。军队嵌入了那个世界的政治中。因为，多米尼克，只是为了重申这一点，正是军队赋予了德国作为最占主导地位的军事强国的地位，不仅在中欧，而且在欧洲。是的。取代了之前拥有该地位的强国，即法国。是的，正是如此。而且法国不仅被那种在凡尔赛的仪式所羞辱，
but it had also been shorn of Alsace and Lorraine. Yes, it absolutely had. And what's more, I think, Germany is still a conglomeration of countries, I suppose you could say, which all happen to speak German. Some are Protestant, some are Catholic. They're very different kind of traditions. But the army, as so often, the army is a kind of, you know, it's an imperial institution. The army embodies German-ness in a way that other things maybe don't really do to the same extent. So the army really matters. But there is more to Germany than its army. It has the world's biggest socialist party. We talked about them at the start of the show.
但它也失去了阿尔萨斯和洛林。是的，绝对失去了。而且更重要的是，我认为，德国仍然是一个国家的集合体，我想你可以这么说，它们恰好都说德语。有些是新教徒，有些是天主教徒。它们有着非常不同的传统。但军队，就像往常一样，军队是一种，你知道的，帝国机构。军队以一种其他事物可能无法企及的程度体现了“德国性”。所以军队真的很重要。但德国不仅仅有军队。它拥有世界上最大的社会主义政党。我们在节目开始时谈到过他们。
Social Democrats, yeah. The fact that they've won a third of the seats. They have. It has the strongest trade union movement in Europe. It has by far the most developed welfare state of any major European country. So in other words, the Kaiser's Germany, it's definitely not the Third Reich. It's not a dictatorship. It's not Sparta. I mean, it has Spartan elements, but it's also, I mean, it's an intellectual powerhouse and therefore it's a scientific powerhouse and therefore it's an industrial
社会民主党，是的。事实上，他们赢得了三分之一的席位。他们确实赢了。它拥有欧洲最强大的工会运动。它是所有欧洲大国中福利国家制度最发达的，遥遥领先。所以换句话说，德皇的德国绝对不是第三帝国。它不是独裁政权。它不是斯巴达。我的意思是，它有斯巴达的元素，但它也是，我的意思是，它是一个知识强国，因此它是一个科学强国，因此它是一个工业
powerhouse. Yeah. It's the world of Thomas Mann and scientists. Exactly. Yeah. And so as a result of that, Germany has rivaled France and maybe surpassed it militarily. And it is starting to rival and perhaps surpass Britain industrially. Yeah. In a way that actually terrifies people, as we will see. But of course, at the top of this system, it's a very colourful person.
强国。是的。这是托马斯·曼和科学家的世界。没错。是的。因此，德国在军事上可以与法国抗衡，甚至可能已经超越了它。它开始在工业上与英国抗衡，甚至可能超越英国。是的。以一种实际上让人们感到恐惧的方式，正如我们将要看到的那样。但当然，在这个系统的顶端，是一个非常有个性的人。
One of history's great loose cannons, system, it's a very colourful person. One of history's great loose cannons, I think it's fair to say. And is he a friend of the rest of his history, Tom? I think he is. I think he has accompanied us throughout many, many years of this podcast. He always pops up and it's great to have him back. Yeah, Kaiser Wilhelm II. And he is the person, I guess, that most of the people listening to this podcast will say, ah, now they've got to the culprit.
历史上最不可预测的人物之一，系统，是一个非常有个性的人。我认为公平地说，他是历史上最不可预测的人物之一。汤姆，他是他其余历史的朋友吗？我想是的。我想他在我们这个播客的许多年里一直陪伴着我们。他总是出现，很高兴他能回来。是的，德皇威廉二世。我想，听这个播客的大多数人会说，啊，现在他们找到了罪魁祸首。
Because it's the Kaiser who caused the First World War, his insane lust for conquest, his ambition to dominate Europe. He glories in suffering. What a terrible man. At the end of the First World War, people in Britain would say, you know, hang the Kaiser. Kaiser is solely responsible. But there are scholars, aren't there, who do still make that case? Oh, there are. Just to say, this is still very much a live issue in history departments. Not all scholars would make that by any case,
因为是德皇引发了第一次世界大战，他疯狂的征服欲望，他统治欧洲的野心。他以苦难为荣。多么可怕的人。在第一次世界大战结束时，英国人会说，你知道，绞死德皇。德皇负有全部责任。但确实有学者仍然坚持这种观点，不是吗？哦，确实有。只是想说，这在历史系仍然是一个非常活跃的话题。并非所有学者都会在任何情况下都这么认为，
Tom. But let's let people make up their own minds. I think what is certainly true is he is an enormously colourful and strange figure, isn't he? So he was born in 1859 and he's the oldest of queen victoria's 42 grandchildren because his mother is british yes because his mother is is vicky who is queen victoria's sort of her favorite child in many ways her daughter who was sent off to marry prince friedrich wilhelm of prussia so in 1859 she is delivered of this boy Wilhelm and everything goes wrong straight away the birth was awful incredibly traumatic he was a breech baby he was almost asphyxiated and the doctors kind of completely panicked god knows what they were doing but they basically tore all the nerves in his neck he's kind of getting him out and as a result his left arm was left completely useless so you
汤姆。但让我们让人们自己做决定。我认为可以肯定的是，他是一个非常有个性且奇怪的人物，不是吗？所以他出生于1859年，是维多利亚女王42个孙辈中的长孙，因为他的母亲是英国人，是的，因为他的母亲是维基，她在许多方面都是维多利亚女王最宠爱的孩子，她的女儿被送去嫁给普鲁士的弗里德里希·威廉王子，所以1859年她生下了这个男孩威廉，一切从一开始就出了问题，出生过程非常糟糕，极其痛苦，他是臀位产，几乎窒息，医生们完全惊慌失措，天知道他们在做什么，但他们基本上撕裂了他脖子上的所有神经，把他拉出来，结果他的左臂完全废了，所以你
know famously when you see pictures of him he's always hiding his left arm or it's sort of tucked into his jacket or it's in his pockets or something and i guess if you're a psychologist and germany and austria are the great homes of psychology as well you would say that perhaps there's some compensation going on in the fact that he will grow up to become you know he'll love a uniform he will but you know become, you know, he'll love a uniform. It will. But you know what? It doesn't actually end there. So there's a guy called John Ruhle. He hates the Kaiser, doesn't he? He hates the Kaiser, but he basically devoted about a thousand years of his life to writing about the Kaiser in this six million page trilogy.
知道，当你看到他的照片时，他总是藏着左臂，或者把它塞进夹克里，或者放在口袋里之类的，我想如果你是心理学家——德国和奥地利也是心理学的伟大发源地——你会说，也许他在某种程度上进行了补偿，因为他长大后会变得，你知道，他会喜欢穿制服，他会，但你知道吗，他会变得，你知道，他会喜欢穿制服。会的。但你知道吗？其实还没完。有个叫约翰·罗尔的人。他讨厌德皇，不是吗？他讨厌德皇，但他基本上把自己生命中的大约一千年都花在了写这本六百万页的三部曲上，专门写德皇。
And he talks in that about basically when the Kaiser was a little boy, I mean, he wasn't the Kaiser then, when Wilhelm was a little boy, his doctors twice a week would plunge his arm, now this will sound weird, into the body of a freshly slaughtered hare. They would put his arm in because they thought it would impart his arm with the vigour and vitality of this dead hare. I'm really surprised by that because I had Germany down as, you know, the home of cutting edge science and medicine. What you're forgetting, Tom, is it is also the home of horrendous spas and spa treatments. I haven't forgotten that. I mean, people who
他在书中谈到，基本上当德皇还是个小男孩时——我的意思是，那时他还不是德皇——当威廉还是个小男孩时，他的医生每周两次会把他的手臂——现在这听起来很奇怪——浸入一只刚宰杀的野兔的尸体里。他们会把他的手臂放进去，因为他们认为这会给他的手臂注入这只死兔子的活力和生命力。我对此感到非常惊讶，因为我一直认为德国是，你知道，尖端科学和医学的发源地。汤姆，你忘记的是，它也是可怕的水疗中心和水疗护理的发源地。我没忘。我的意思是，听过我们关于“长刀之夜”那一集的人会知道，我们喜欢德国政治悲剧中的水疗小镇。但我的意思是，那确实是非常斯巴达式的。是的。哦，确实。这看起来不像20世纪初的尖端科学，那是我会将德国与之联系起来的东西。1860年代的普鲁士，我不知道。哦，我想是的。是的，我想这更早，但看起来仍然很奇怪。
listened to our episode on the Night of the Long Knives will know that we love a spa town in a German political tragedy. But I mean, that really is something that's quite Spartan. Yeah. Oh, it is. It doesn't seem the cutting edge of early 20th century science, which is what I would associate Germany with. 1860s Prussia, I don't know. Oh, I suppose it is. Yes, I suppose it is earlier, but it still seems odd.
你在寻找更先进的进步医学吗？他们有。是的，继续。他们还做什么？他们有一台拉伸你头部的机器。哦，不。所以他们会把这个，当他还是个蹒跚学步的孩子时，他们会把他放进这台机器里，然后，我不知道，这和虎钳正好相反。
Are you after more advanced progressive medicine? They've got it. Yeah, go on. What else do they do? They've got a machine for stretching your head. Oh, no. So they would put this, when he was like a toddler, they would put him in this machine and sort of, I don't know, it's the opposite of a vice.
它会把你的头拉长。哦。总之，他们有那个。有点像希斯·罗宾逊式的装置。头发凌乱的教授。是的，希斯·罗宾逊式的装置。这对他一点好处都没有。所以多年来，他的右耳一直流着刺鼻的脓液。
It kind of stretches your head out. Oh. Anyway, they've got that. Kind of Heath Robinson device. Scatty haired professors. Yeah, Heath Robinson device. It didn't do him any good. So for years, he's got this pungent pus oozing from his right ear.
基本上，它一直流到他三十多岁，最后他们说，看，他的耳膜必须切除。他们切除了他的耳膜。我真的开始同情他了。如果你还没感到同情，他的母亲维基，英国人，但表现非常糟糕，因为她对他说，你是个残废。你的谈话配不上你。他五岁时她就对他说了这些。然后她说，没有女士会因为你的黑手指而要你。什么是他的黑手指？我想那是他的手臂。
And basically, it oozed continually until his late thirties when eventually they said, look, his eardrum's got to go. They took his eardrum out. I'm really starting to feel sympathy for him. If you're not feeling sympathy already, his mother, Vicky, British, but behaves very poorly because she said to him, you're a cripple. Your conversation is beneath you. He was five years old when she told him this. And then she said, no lady will ever have you with your black finger. What's his black finger? I think that's his arm.
哦，那不是好的教养，对吧？想象一下对你的儿子说那样的话。我的意思是，疯了。他的心理健康一定很糟糕。他的心理健康非常差，因为他还有这些可怕的导师，强迫他工作。他必须在早上六点开始工作，一直工作到晚上十点。现在，汤姆，你和我现在这样做，准备《历史的其余部分》的剧集。我们确实这样做。但我们七岁时没这样做。所以你提到了德皇的心理健康。他曾经对他的一个朋友说，我身上缺少别人
Oh, that's not good parenting, is it? Imagine saying that to your son. I mean, mad. He must have very bad mental health. He's very poor mental health because he also has these terrible tutors who force him to work. He has to start work at six o'clock in the morning and work all the way through till 10 o'clock at night. Now, Tom, you and I do that now, preparing episodes of The Rest is History. We do. But we didn't do that when we were seven. So you said about the Kaiser's mental health. He once said to one of his friends, something is missing in me that other people
拥有的东西。我内心所有的诗意感受都已经死了，已经被扼杀了。天哪，他真的需要更好的帮助。是的，他绝对需要。但汤姆，你看到了吗？克里斯托弗·克拉克，他也是德皇的传记作者，但比约翰·罗尔更具同情心，在他的书《梦游者》中谈到了德皇的，他所谓的“疯狂的胡言乱语”。所以你的笔记里有一个标题，是用黑体字写的，所以我不会错过。外交界的汤姆·霍兰德。我不知道你是什么意思。你在说什么？你是说我有愚蠢的胡言乱语吗？
have. All poetic feeling in me has been dead and has been killed. God, he really needs better help. Yeah, he definitely does. But also, Tom, did you see this? Christopher Clarke, who's also a biographer of the Kaiser, but more sympathetic than John Rowe, talks in his book, The Sleepwalkers, about the Kaiser's, what he calls his insane burblings. So in your notes, you have this under a heading, which is in black print, so I won't miss it. The Tom Holland of the diplomatic world. I don't know what you mean by that. What are you saying? Are you saying I have inane burblings?
你喜欢搞阴谋。你喜欢搞花招。你喜欢愚蠢的胡言乱语。你知道吗？我有吗？哦，好吧。你会否认吗？你能看着我的眼睛否认吗，汤姆？
You love a scheme. You love a wheeze. You love an inane burble. You know? Do I? Oh, okay. Would you deny that? Can you look me in the eye and deny that, Tom?
我不认为那是愚蠢的胡言乱语。我认为它们切中要害。好吧，我的意思是，德皇，我告诉你他的疯狂胡言乱语。在19世纪90年代末，他建议在巴西中部的亚马逊雨林建立一个德国殖民地，叫“新德国”。他告诉每个人鼓励移民。显然，每个人都无视他。1899年，也就是几年后，他说，其实，我改变主意了。
I don't think they're inane burblings. I think they're to the point. Well, I mean, the Kaiser, I'll tell you about his insane burblings. In the late 1890s, he suggested founding a German colony in the middle of Brazil in the Amazon rainforest called New Germany. And he told everybody to encourage immigration. Everyone ignored him, obviously. In 1899, so just a few years later, he said, actually, I've changed my mind.
我认为我们应该在美索不达米亚，在美索不达米亚的沙漠里建立一个德国殖民地。他在1900年试图瓜分中国。三年后，他突然让他的助手们震惊，他说，拉丁美洲是我们的目标。他命令海军部准备入侵古巴、波多黎各和纽约的计划。好吧。这都很有趣，但我还是想回到，这在什么方面像我？疯狂的计划。考虑不周的计划，汤姆。我认为这就是指控。你不想做一个关于查塔姆商业街的播客吗？我想做，而且我们会的。
I think we should have a German colony in Mesopotamia, in the desert in Mesopotamia. He tried to partition China in 1900. Three years after that, he suddenly stunned his aides by saying, Latin America is our target. And he ordered the admiralty to prepare invasion plans of Cuba, Puerto Rico, and New York. Okay. That's all very interesting, but I still want to come back to, in what way is that like me? Mad schemes. Ill-thought-out schemes, Tom. I think that's the claim. Do you not want to do a podcast about Chatham High Street? I do, and we're going to.
这就是区别。是的。因为这些事情都没有发生，但我们将要做一集关于查塔姆商业街的节目。好吧。但总之，他总是提出联盟计划。所以他会说，听着，克里斯·克拉克有一个非常有趣的名单，与俄罗斯和法国结盟对抗日本和英国，
That's the difference. Yeah. Because none of these things happened, but we are going to be doing an episode on Chatham High Street. Right. But anyway, so he's always come up with alliance projects as well. So he will say, listen, Chris Clark has a very amusing list with Russia and France against Japan and Britain,
与日本和美国结盟对抗英国，俄罗斯和法国结盟对抗日本和英国，与日本和美国结盟对抗英国，俄罗斯和法国，与中国和美国结盟对抗日本和俄罗斯。他就像一个拿着一堆牌的人，把它们混在一起。但公平地说，多米尼克，对任何玩过《外交》游戏的人来说，公平地说，这可能相当精明。这就是你在游戏中做的事情。确实。你不断地结盟，然后背后捅人一刀。你看，他喜欢这样。他会做的是，他会举办晚宴。我们曾经谈过
with Japan and the United States against Britain, Russia and France against Japan and Britain, with Japan and the United States against Britain, Russia and France, with China and the United States against Japan and Russia. He's like a man with a load of cards and he's mixing them up. But to be fair, Dominic, to be fair to anyone who's played the game Diplomacy, I mean, this could be quite kind of shrewd. This is what you do in the game. It is. You're constantly making alliances and then stabbing people in the back. He loves this, you see. And what he will do is he will have his dinner parties. We talked once
在我们“历史上最灾难性的派对”那一集中，关于他与迪特里希·格拉夫·冯·许尔森-海斯勒的灾难性狩猎旅行，那个人打扮成芭蕾舞演员，在旋转舞步中途死去了。所以这些人会聚集在一起。当他们打扮
in our History's Most Disastrous Parties episode about his disastrous hunting trip with Dietrich Graf von Hülsenhäisler, who dressed up as a ballerina and died in mid-pirouette. So these people will gather. And when they're dressing
成芭蕾舞演员并死去时，德皇对他们说，我们为什么不和葡萄牙人联手入侵巴拉圭呢？你知道，他只会喋喋不休地说这些废话。所以克里斯·克拉克说，他是爱德华时代那种社会阶层的极端典型。那个永远在向旁边的人解释某种宠爱项目的俱乐部无聊者。当然，旁边的人，因为他是德国皇帝，旁边的人通常是来访的皇室成员、国家元首。美国大使，诸如此类的。
as ballerinas and dying, the Kaiser is saying to them, why don't we team up with the Portuguese and invade Paraguay? You know, he'll be just wittering this nonsense. So Chris Clark says he was an extreme exemplar of that Edwardian social category. The club bore who is forever explaining some pet project to the man in the next chair. And of course, the man in the next chair, because he's the Kaiser of Germany, the man in the next chair is usually a visiting royal, a head of state. The American ambassador, that kind of thing.
是的，他们总是会感到震惊。保加利亚国王斐迪南，他实际上是德国人，德皇在公共场合拍了他的屁股。显然，他带着极度的仇恨离开了柏林，因为受到了如此羞辱。你知道，随着每一个轶事，我对德皇的感觉越来越好。比利时国王利奥波德，就是那个在刚果丢尽脸面的利奥波德。他去柏林参加德皇的生日派对。德皇当时认为开个玩笑很有趣，说，
Yeah, who will always be horrified. King Ferdinand of Bulgaria, who was actually German, the Kaiser smacked him on the bottom in public. And apparently he left Berlin white hot with hatred, having been so humiliated. Do you know, I'm feeling fonder and fonder of the Kaiser with each anecdote. King Leopold of the Belgians, so this is the Leopold who disgraced himself in the Congo. He went to Berlin for the Kaiser's birthday party. And the Kaiser at that thought it was amusing banter to say,
我想试着攻击法国。如果你加入我，我会给你旧勃艮第的王冠。利奥波德显然对此非常不安，以至于他离开派对时，头盔戴反了。我只是觉得他太脆弱了，但当然，德皇的主要目标是英国。现在，他血统上有一半是英国人，所以你可以说那里发生了什么？答案很明显。他讨厌他的父母，他们是真正的亲英派，因为他们把他的头放进机器里，强迫他的手臂进入死兔子的尸体。你认为他把这与英国联系起来了吗，
I fancy having a crack at the French. If you join me i will give you the crown of old burgundy and leopold was so upset by this apparently that when he left the party he's wearing his helmet the wrong way around i just think he's being a snowflake there but of course the kaiser's great target is britain now he is half british by blood so you could say what's going on there and the the answer is obvious. He hated his parents, who were real Anglophiles, because they'd been putting his head into a machine and forcing his arm into the dead body of a hare. And do you think he associates this with Britain,
那种医疗器械的折磨？这是英国式的教养方式。是的，我认为德皇最棒的地方在于，他是一个如此有趣的人物，一方面，他显然崇拜英国。他认为英国是典范。他想和英国军官一起去游艇旅行。这就是考斯穿错鞋的全部意义所在。是的。他不想被英国人冷落。不。他想被他们钦佩。实际上他确实很受英国人钦佩，不是吗？所以在爱德华七世的葬礼上，威廉真的很讨厌他。称他为撒旦。你看。我的意思是，那是仇恨。但他从人群中得到了最响亮的欢呼。
kind of torture by medical contraptions? This is the British way of parenthood. Yeah, I think the great thing with the Kaiser that makes him so entertaining a character is that on the one hand, he clearly worships Britain. He thinks Britain is the exemplar. He wants to go yachting with British officers. And this is the whole point of the wrong shoes at cow stuff. Yeah. He does not want to be snubbed by the British. No. He wants to be admired by them. And actually he is quite admired by the British, isn't he? So at the funeral of Edward VII, who Wilhelm really hates. Called him Satan. There you go. I mean, that's hatred. But he gets the loudest cheers from the crowd.
是的。你看，他是一个有个性的人。英国人喜欢有个性的人，不是吗？是的。他经常在英国丢脸，因为他接受了《每日电讯报》的一次灾难性采访，在采访中他说，英国人像三月的野兔一样疯狂。他们不喜欢我，但他们应该爱我、尊重我。我告诉你，他们绝对疯了。
Yeah. He's a character, you see. The British love a character, don't they? Yeah. He's often disgracing himself in Britain because he gave a disastrous interview to the Daily Telegraph in which he said, the English are as mad as March hares. They don't like me, but they should love and respect me. They're absolutely mad, I tell you.
疯了。他们印了这个。这非常令人尴尬。基本上，这是他自己的外交部多次禁止他接受更多采访的原因之一，因为他们说他完全不可靠。我认为正如我所说，他是维多利亚女王的长孙。英国在某种程度上是母国。他希望自己的国家德国被认真对待。当他去英国时，他希望自己被认真对待。关于穿错鞋的事情，有一种感觉，每个人都在一直嘲笑他。当然，对于一个基本上仍然是个小男孩的人来说，你知道，他的左臂没用，他一直
Mad. And they printed this. and it was incredibly embarrassing. And basically, this was one of the many occasions when his own foreign office sort of banned him from giving more interviews because they said he's totally unreliable. I think what it is, as I said, he's Queen Victoria's oldest grandchild. Britain is, as it were, to some extent, the mother country. He wants his own country, Germany, to be taken seriously. He wants to be taken seriously himself when he goes to Britain. And the whole wrong shoes thing, there is a sense that everybody's laughing at him the whole time. And of course, for somebody who basically is still the little boy, who, you know, his left arm is useless, he has been
被医生残酷地折磨，所有这些，你绝对可以理解为什么这会侵蚀你的自信心。这也是英国那种漫不经心的优越感表现的时期，不是吗？这体现在男装剪裁和我们在那一集中谈论的所有事情上，以及游艇和帆船赛。英国正在制定社会顶层人士应该如何表现的规则。显然，这是让德皇感到愤怒的事情。是的，绝对是，汤姆。现在，这一切重要吗？这就是问题所在。这在这个系列中重要吗？现在，如果你是约翰·罗尔，他的传记作者，你会说这很重要，
hideously tortured by his doctors, all of that, you can absolutely understand why that would eat away at your self-confidence. It's also the kind of the languid period, isn't it, of Britain's affectation of effortless superiority, which is expressed in men's tailoring and everything that we were talking about in our episode on that, and the yachting and the regattas. Britain is setting the rules on how people at the top end of society should behave. And clearly, this is something that burns the Kaiser up. Yeah, absolutely it does, Tom. Now, does all this matter? That's the question. Does this matter in this series? Now, if you're John Rule, his biographer, you say it does matter, that the
德皇被仇恨吞噬，变成了一个怪物，一个恶霸和吹牛者，他将指导政策。另一方面，即使是对德国相当严厉的历史学家，像马克斯·黑斯廷斯这样的人，他也说德皇最终是一个相当滑稽的人物。他是肯尼斯·格雷厄姆笔下“蟾蜍先生”的穿制服版本。问题是，德皇不是独裁者，也不是绝对君主。有很多例子，通常非常有趣，他的员工完全无视他，你知道，在背后嘲笑他。这就是你拿他和我比较的原因。
Kaiser is eaten up by hatred and has become a monstrous figure, a bully and a braggart, and that he will direct policy. On the other hand, even historians who are quite tough on Germany, someone like Max Hastings, he says ultimately the Kaiser is quite a comic figure. He is a uniformed version of Kenneth Graham's Mr. Toad. And the thing is, the Kaiser is not a dictator and he's not an absolute monarch. And there are lots of examples, often very amusing, of his staff just completely ignoring him, you know, laughing at him behind his back. This is why you're comparing him to me.
谢谢。不，一点也不，汤姆。我会报复的，多米尼克，即使这让戈德汉格陷入世界大战。一点也不。你看到那个关于他在1908年写信给西奥多·罗斯福的精彩故事了吗？所以他写了一封信给西奥多·罗斯福，
Thanks. No, not at all, Tom. I will have my revenge, Dominic, even if it plunges Goldhanger into world war. Not at all. Do you see this wonderful story about him writing a letter to Theodore Roosevelt in 1908? So he wrote a letter to Theodore Roosevelt,
德国大使拒绝把它交给罗斯福。他在私下里对其他大使说，德国皇帝写信给美国总统，就像一个迷恋的学徒写信给漂亮的裁缝一样，这不合适。我不知道信里写了什么。火辣的内容。总之，关于德皇，我们可以说的一件值得钦佩的事情是，他是一个伟大的朋友，正如我们在萨拉热窝系列中谈到的那样，
and the German ambassador refused to give it to Roosevelt. And he said in private to the other ambassadors, it's not appropriate for the emperor of Germany to write to the president of the United States as an infatuated schoolboy might write to a pretty seamstress. I don't know what was in the letter. Scorching stuff. Anyway, the one thing we can say about the Kaiser that is admirable, he is a great friend, as we talked about in our Sarajevo series,
弗朗茨·斐迪南和索菲的朋友。所以当其他人因为索菲只是个公爵夫人或者别的什么——伯爵夫人——而冷落她时，德皇在这方面实际上做得很好。德皇说，不，不，你们可以作为平等的人来到我的城堡。我们可以一起射杀很多鸟。在那方面，他很像我。真的吗？善良。
of Franz Ferdinand and Sophie. So when other people are snubbing Sophie because she's only a duchess or whatever she was, countess, the Kaiser is actually really good on this. And the Kaiser says, no, no, you can come as equals to my castle. We can shoot loads of birds together. In that way, he is quite like me. Really? Kind.
最终是一个善良的人。最终是一个善良的人。我不拘礼节。不。当我邀请人们去我的苏格兰庄园参加射击派对时。不，你没有。不，你没有，汤姆。这是我经常对你说的。
Ultimately a kind person. Ultimately a kind person. I don't stand on ceremony. No. When I invite people to shooting parties on my Scottish estate. No, you don't. No, you don't, Tom. It's one thing I've often said about you.
是的。你会和各种背景的人交往，不是吗？我当然会。可爱。而且我喜欢的另一件事，当然是波罗的海的游艇假期。是的。你会和各种背景的人交往，不是吗？我当然会。可爱。而且我喜欢的另一件事，当然是波罗的海的游艇假期。
Yeah. That you will associate with people from all backgrounds, won't you? I certainly will. Lovely. And also the other thing I love, of course, is a yachting holiday in the Baltic. Yeah. That you will associate with people from all backgrounds, won't you? I certainly will. Lovely. And also the other thing I love, of course, is the yachting holiday in the Baltic.
是的。他也喜欢那个。当他发现他的朋友弗朗茨·斐迪南和索菲被谋杀的噩耗时，他正在游艇上。
Yeah. He loves that as well. He's on one when he finds out the terrible news that his friend Franz Ferdinand and Sophie have been murdered.
6月28日星期日下午，他在波罗的海的游艇上参加基尔帆船赛。基尔帆船赛实际上是一个非常棒的
On the afternoon of Sunday the 28th of June is in the Baltic on his yacht in the Kiel Regatta. And the Kiel Regatta is actually a brilliant place of kind of
英德友谊之地。有很多干杯和玩笑。我确实喜欢游艇在第一次世界大战前夕频繁出现的方式。哦，好。那很好。这是另一个例子。
Anglo-German friendship. There's lots of kind of drinkier toasts and bants. I do like the way that yachts will be appearing regularly throughout the build up to the First World War. Oh, good. That's nice. This is another example of it.
是的。他以一种非常爱德华时代的游艇方式得知了这个消息。所以他正要乘游艇出发，一艘摩托艇靠了过来，急促地鸣笛。摩托艇上是海军内阁首脑格奥尔格·冯·穆勒海军上将。他扔上烟盒，一个人接住烟盒，打开它。那是给德皇的一张便条，上面写着，弗朗茨·斐迪南和索菲被谋杀。德皇，血色从他脸上褪去。他变得苍白，他说——我不知道他为什么这么说，但这就是他说的。
Yeah. He learns the news in a very Edwardian yachting way. So he's about to set off on his yacht and a motor launch comes alongside, blowing its horn urgently. And on the motor launch is Admiral Georg von Muller, who is the head of his naval cabinet. And he throws up his cigarette case and a guy catches the cigarette case, opens it. It's a note for the Kaiser and it says, Franz Ferdinand and Sophie have been murdered. And the Kaiser, the blood drains from his face. He turns pale and he says, I don't know why he says this, but this is what he says.
他说，一切都必须重新开始。他非常难过。我认为通常当人们讲述这个故事时，即使是写这个故事的非常伟大的历史学家有时也会忘记德皇不仅仅是一个笑话。他实际上是一个人，这是他仅有的几个朋友之一。他对此感到非常难过和困扰。而且是一位被暗杀的皇室同僚。是的。
He says, everything has to start again. And he's very upset. I think often when people tell this story, even very great historians who write this story sometimes forget that the Kaiser is not just a joke. He is actually a human being and that this was one of his only friends. And he's genuinely upset about it and troubled. And is a fellow royal who's been assassinated. Yeah.
在一个皇室成员经常被暗杀的世界里，对吧？所以这是一件可怕的事情。所以我们知道，他在暗杀发生后的几天里写道，塞尔维亚人需要被解决。这是他脑子里想的事情。另一方面，在过去十年左右的时间里，他几乎对欧洲的每个国家都写过这样的话。关于德皇的事情是，他非常好战，
In a world when, you know, royals are often being assassinated, right? So it's a frightening thing. So we know that he scribbles in the days after the assassination, the Serbs need to be sorted out. This is something that is on his mind. On the other hand, he's written that about almost every country in Europe in the last 10 years or so. And the thing with the Kaiser is he's very bellicose,
他总是想出这些疯狂的想法，关于查塔姆商业街的播客，等等。然而，他实际上没有发动战争的记录。他从未入侵过任何人。他从未攻击过另一个欧洲国家。德国人确实在西南非洲参与了非常可怕的行动。但那场战役，实际上，在他在位之前，他们就已经到达那里，开始了所有这些事情。当然，
and he's always coming up with these mad ideas, podcasts about Chatham High Street, you name it. However, he actually has no record of starting a war. He has never invaded anybody. He's never attacked another European country. The Germans have been involved in southwest Africa very horrifically. But that campaign, actually, they'd got there, they'd started all that business before he even became emperor. And of course,
所有欧洲国家在非洲的表现都很糟糕。在欧洲的背景下，他是弗朗茨·斐迪南的朋友，弗朗茨·斐迪南是一个和平主义者。一个和平倡导者。他曾多次就此站在弗朗茨·斐迪南一边。他曾经对弗朗茨·斐迪南开过一个玩笑。他说，你们奥地利人，我希望你们停止用我的军刀乱晃。是的，非常好。我也是一个和平主义者，多米尼克。他说，你们奥地利人，我希望你们停止用我的军刀乱晃。是的，非常好。我也是一个和平主义者，多米尼克。所以，又是一个相似之处。
all European countries are behaving badly in Africa. And in the context of Europe, he's friends with Franz Ferdinand, who is a man of peace. A peace advocate. He has repeatedly sided with Franz Ferdinand about that. And he once made a joke to Franz Ferdinand. He said, you Austrians, I wish you'd stop rattling with my saber. Yeah, very good. I'm also a man of peace, Dominand. He said, you Austrians, I wish you'd stop rattling with my saber. Yeah, very good. I'm also a man of peace, Dominic. So again, another point of resemblance.
在这个播客的核心，确实有一种弗朗茨·斐迪南和威廉二世的氛围，不是吗，迪恩，我想？是的，我想是的。所以我认为德皇实际上是这一时期许多德国人的典型代表。
There's very much a Franz Ferdinand Wilhelm II vibe at the heart of this podcast, isn't there, Dean, I think? Yeah, I think there is. So I think the Kaiser is actually quite typical of a lot of the Germans in this period.
所以我们将在后面的一集中谈论他们的总参谋长，策划第一次世界大战初期德国战役的人，即小赫尔穆特·冯·毛奇将军。毛奇总是对奥地利人说，如果发生战争，我们会站在你们一边，但不要发动它。请不要发动战争。我们会支持你们。有一天，条顿人和斯拉夫人会打一仗。当然，在19世纪末20世纪初，很多人相信这一点，因为这是种族思维和社会达尔文主义思维的时代。
So we will talk in a later episode about their chief general, the man who masterminds the opening German campaigns of the First World War, who is General Helmut von Moltke, the younger. Moltke has always said to the Austrians, if there is ever a war, we will stand beside you, but don't start it. Please don't start a war. We'll be there for you. One day, the Teutons and the Slavs will fight it out. Of course, loads of people believe this in the late 19th, early 20th century, because it's the age of kind of racial thinking and social Darwinist thinking.
但毛奇明确表示，有一天会发生一场战争，这将是德意志民族和斯拉夫民族之间的斗争，但攻击必须来自斯拉夫人，即让他们开始，但我们不能开始。这就是情况。事实上，奥地利人坐在那里，被萨赫蛋糕包围着，留着巨大的胡子说，让我们攻击塞尔维亚人吧，他们最大的担心是德国人会让我们失望。德国人只会说空话，永远不会付诸行动。我的意思是，传统上德国人的形象就是这样，他们是某种梦想的理想主义者。
But Moltke had said explicitly, there will one day be a war, which will be a struggle between Germandom and Slavdom, but the attack must come from the Slavs, i.e. let them start it, but we can't start it. So that is the situation. In fact, the Austrians, as they're sitting there, surrounded by Sascha Torte with their enormous moustaches saying, let's have a crack at the Serbs, their big worry is the Germans will let us down. The Germans are all talk and they'll never follow through. I mean, that traditionally has been the image of the Germans, that they are kind of dreamy idealists.
我想即使在他们攻击法国等等的时候，也有一种那种遗产。是的。但奥地利人对此绝对坚定。康拉德将军，贝希托尔德伯爵，他们认为如果我们现在不抓住这个机会，那就是我们帝国的终结。实际上，我认为他们也认为我们亏欠弗朗茨·斐迪南，当然，他是一个和平主义者，他给了塞尔维亚人所有可能的自由，而他们通过谋杀他来回报他。
And I guess there's a kind of legacy of that, even as they kind of go, you know, attacking the French and so on. Yeah. But the Austrians are absolutely set on this. General Conrad, Count von Berchtold, they think if we do not take this chance now, it is the end of our empire. And actually, I think they also think we owe it to Franz Ferdinand, that sure, he was a man of peace and he gave the Serbs every possible latitude and they rewarded him for it by murdering him.
现在我们必须为他报仇。所以贝希托尔德伯爵说，我要派我的参谋长去。他是个年轻人。他叫亚历山大·霍约斯伯爵。他很年轻，但经验丰富，是个强硬派。我会派霍约斯去柏林亲自与德国人讨论。他们给了他两份文件。一份是某种一般性的备忘录。另一份是弗朗茨·约瑟夫皇帝写给德皇的个人信件，解释了他想要什么。汤姆，正是在那封信上，欧洲的命运将发生转变。所以让我们结束今天的节目。在下一集中，你可以找出这两封信对德皇、对德奥联盟的影响，以及由此延伸，那些在俄罗斯、在
And now we have to avenge him. So Count Berchtold says, I'm going to send my chief of staff. He's a younger guy. He's called Count Alexander Hoyos. He's young, but he's very experienced and he's a kind of hardliner. I will send Hoyos to Berlin to discuss with the Germans in person. And they give him two documents. One is a kind of general memorandum. The other is a personal letter from the Emperor Franz Joseph to the Kaiser explaining exactly what he wants. And it's on that letter, Tom, that the fortunes of Europe will turn. So let's finish today's episode. And in the next episode, you can find out what the impact of those two letters are on the Kaiser, on the alliance between Germany and Austria, and by extension, how people who are opposed to Germany and Austria in Russia, in
法国，甚至在英国反对德国和奥地利的人将如何反应。所以那很快就会出来。但如果你想要下一集以及关于第一次世界大战爆发之路的整个系列，那么你可以通过注册“历史的其余部分”俱乐部一次性获得它们，你可以在 therestishistory.com 找到。在那之前，再见。Auf Wiedersehen。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们一起主持《娱乐的其余部分》
France, and even in Britain will react. So that'll be coming out very soon. But if you want the next episode and all of this series on the road to the outbreak of the First World War, then you can get them all in one go by signing up to The Rest Is History Club, which you can find at therestishistory.com. Until then, goodbye. Auf Wiedersehen. I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment
这是你每周的娱乐新闻评论、一点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的
it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com 这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果您想收听无广告内容、获取额外剧集并优先购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。